stoned as a [ __ ] and go on stay
so friday i went to the store and i
swear to god guys i didn't eat nothing
all dad smoked some pot i worked that
before i left the house
there was a little brownie
a 70 milligram brownie
i had like maybe 13 carbs left for the
day
i was [ __ ] starving
this little brownie is right there it
was a half a pack of an anarchy edible
they give you two brownies each brownie
is 70 milligrams that's so crazy that's
so scary i rub my balls at 70 milligrams
you understand me 70 milligrams for
uncle joey is like an apparent thief
it's not even a [ __ ] explain to the
rest of the world 70 milligrams will put
you into a [ __ ] hole do you know i
gave him 500 last night
jesus christ
oh my god listen to me though we split
it at three o'clock in the afternoon oh
my god what are you trying to prove by
seven o'clock i was so [ __ ] up
by eight o'clock and you know what
usually when you eat you tame that
animal [ __ ] no
this turned on me
this edible turn young me dog like a
savage he beat me into submissions at
one point i had the cheese doodles that
belongs to the baby pirates booty yeah
they were on the floor they were just
coming out of my face i was just
i was just stuffing pirates booty in my
face and a pear
i couldn't stop
i kept eating peaches and pirates booty
there's a pirate's booty cantaloupe and
pirates booty i must hate the whole even
my wife was like because i had my back
turned to them so they couldn't see me
my wife's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing in here
i go listen i gotta go to bed she goes
go to bed already i went to bed at 8 45
i slept on four i got up i didn't know
where i was i just laid here for 30
minutes like mad max i just laid there
i'll come to you
see we'll kill four in the morning you
didn't know where you were so low at 4
30. i woke up with a ton of energy a lot
of energy i wanted to shower i washed
the car i went for breakfast oh my god i
was [ __ ] up and i kept calling lee and
saying lee if the cops call you don't
answer the phone he goes why are the
cops on the corner